so on a darker topic you've expressed
serious concern about existential
threats of AI it's perhaps one of the
greatest challenges our civilization
faces but since I would say we're kind
of an optimistic descendants of Apes
perhaps we can find several paths of
escaping the harm of AI so if I can give
you three options maybe you can comment
which do you think is the most promising
so one is scaling up efforts on AI
safety and beneficial high research in
hope of finding an algorithmic or maybe
a policy solution two is becoming a
multiplanetary species as quickly as
possible and three is merging with AI
and riding the wave of that increasing
intelligence as it continuously improves
what do you think is most promising most
interesting as a civilization that we
should invest in I think this this a lot
that respond to investment going on in
AI where there's a lack of investment is
in AI safety and there should be in my
view a cup of agency that oversees
anything related to AI to confirm that
it is does not represent a public safety
risk just as there is a regulatory
authority for this like the Food and
Drug Administration is that's the for
automotive safety there's the FA for
aircraft safety which generally comes a
conclusion that it is important to have
a government referee or a referee that
is serving the public interest in
ensuring that things are safe when when
there's a potential danger to the public
I would argue that AI is unequivocally
something that has potential to be
dangerous to the public and therefore
should have a regulatory agency just as
other things that are dangerous to the
public have a regulatory agency but let
me tell you problems with this is that
the government moves very slowly and the
rate of the rate the usually way a
regulatory agency comes into being is
that something terrible happens
a huge public outcry and years after
that there's a regulatory agency were
all put in place take something like
like seatbelts it was known for on a
decade or more
that seatbelts would have a massive
impact on safety and and save so many
lives in serious injuries and the car
industry fought the requirements put
seatbelts in tooth and nail that's crazy
yeah and and honor hundreds of thousands
of people probably died because of that
and they said people wouldn't buy cars
if their seatbelts which is obviously
absurd you know or look at the back
tobacco industry and how long they
fought any good thing about smoking
that's part of why I helped make that
movie thank you for smoking you can sort
of see just how pernicious it can be
when you have these companies
effectively achieve regulatory capture
of government the bad people in the AG
community refer to the advent of digital
superintelligence as a singularity that
that is not to say that it is good or
bad but it that it is very difficult to
predict what will happen after that
point and and then there's some
probability it will be bad some probably
will be it will be good or if they want
you to defect that probability and have
it be more good than bad
you